this is a production of cornell
university
that are commercially available and
a small colony that needs to be
redeployed every
six to eight weeks or so
or you could also use mechanical
ventilation
in in the small scale of research that
we have at cornell it wasn't practical
for us to obtain bumble bees so we
actually used a
um a leaf blower um this was a battery
operated leaf blower that was not very
powerful and we kind of throttled it
down and so once a day we would move
through the
crop
and
tried to carefully
blow the flower clusters to mechanically
pollinate them
it was decently effective but we would
we would periodically see misshapen
fruit indicating that there was poor
pollination of our flowers
so these rows are typically spaced about
three feet apart
sometimes slightly tighter spacing 2.6
to 3.3
feet apart
and then
that would give us a plant density
of so if this slab is about three feet
long or a meter long and they're spaced
a meter apart we'd have anywhere from
eight to twelve plants per square meter
or about uh one plant just under just
over per um square foot per plant
so some of the the benefits of growing
in
greenhouses or high tunnels would be
season extension or year-round
production
we can have reduced disease and we
certainly see this in cases where in a
in a high tunnel for example we're
protecting our plant from
from rain water
that that can damage the the fruit it
can lead to leaf-borne pathogens
similarly in a greenhouse we would have
that that benefit we can also control
the the relative humidity and the air
flow
to reduce
those foliar diseases
um we can also grow where there's poor
soil drainage in in the underlying field
and then
there are some really nice gains in
labor ergonomics so we're not bending
down to work in the
crop that's planted into the ground but
the crop is at waist height or slightly
higher
and so it's easier to to transplant
and
pick fruit for example and maintain the
crop
and overall because we're in an
environment where we either have some
control or even more control with with
the temperature and adding supplemental
light in some cases
we get higher yield and quality
than outdoors
some of the some of the cons that we
have to think about is
it is a
soilless substrate production requires
more precise irrigation and
fertilization practices so this would
typically include weekly monitoring
of the root zone
ph and and fertility level or electrical
conductivity
periodically sending samples to
like leaf tissue samples to a lab for
analysis to make sure that our
fertilizer program is on track
and then periodically monitoring and
adjusting the the amount of irrigation
water that we're supplying
at each irrigation event
so it also requires more more time and
more money for controlling the
environment
we still see a proliferation of insects
often so mites thrips
and aphids
and so
then you also have to establish an
integrated pest management program
and a lot of times in a greenhouse that
would focus on using
beneficial insects so good bugs that
fight bad bugs um as well as there are
some examples of
typically there's their softer
pesticides that are registered for
um an edible crop in the greenhouse
and we definitely have higher production
costs than in a field
we do have higher output as well
i remember there was a study from from
the university of arizona that even in a
in an arizona greenhouse which requires
a lot less heat and supplemental light
than a new york greenhouse they were
looking at input costs of about four
dollars per pound of strawberries um and
so you have to think about how you would
differentiate differentiate your product
um to bring a higher uh price at market
and some of that could be the off-season
production but you would need to produce
a high quality flavorful product that's
going to
bring consumers out
just a little bit about cultivars
typically in high tunnels we're looking
at using day neutral cultivars um a
little bit later i'll show you some
specific examples of that um and so we
use these ever-bearing cultivars so that
we can take advantage of an extended
growing season and we would harvest them
over multiple months in the high tunnel
in a greenhouse or vertical farm
we can use either day neutral or short
day cultivars so day neutral could give
us several months of
harvesting
for short day plants
these could be more productive because
they'll give us you know a large flush
of fruit and so these would be plants
that that were growing up ahead of time
kept in coolers until we want to force
them or establish them in the greenhouse
for fruiting
and then we would we would have
several crop cycles per year so this
would take quite a bit of labor
to to bring our plants out of the cooler
force them to to fruit and let them
fruit for for a few months and then take
them out again
um and so
um in a in a greenhouse often our
limiting factor for when we can can grow
these plants is it's really hard to
maintain cool enough conditions in the
summer time depending on on your climate
new york has has different climates
but if we have high night temperatures
so night temperatures above about
um
if they're higher than the low 60s
we get poorer berry production and we
get poorer fruit quality so the fruit
are not as
sweet
and with our cultivar selection we have
to consider again that market
differentiation so choosing cultivars
that have
good flavor and quality
just a little bit about the
environmental conditions so we're
looking at
day temperatures of 68 to 75 degrees
fahrenheit
ideal night temperatures are quite cool
50 to 54 degrees fahrenheit on those
lower temperatures give us larger fruit
size and better
flavor and sweetness of berries
and then above 60 to 65
leads to higher acidity levels so we get
a
more acidic fruit
the optimum light that we would get is
is
fairly moderate kind of sunlight
conditions
and if you if we talk about light
in moles per meter squared per day
um we'd be in between a lettuce plant
and a tomato plant for example so
lettuce would have about 15 moles of
light per day tomatoes we'd have about
30 moles of light per day
and so
we would want 20 to 25 which means in
the winter time if we want a good output
from our crop we would definitely have
to use supplemental lighting
similarly many greenhouse growers in the
winter time
would enrich with carbon dioxide to make
to improve crop productivity so co2
feeds into photosynthesis and that
include improves our crop yield by
maybe 20 to 30 percent
um and then humidity is uh 40 to 60
during the day and then during the night
we actually want to have high humidity
and i'll explain that for a minute so
three hours at 95 humidity at night
so a typical greenhouse production
schedule would have us
say transplanting
will develop tray plants
so plants that were previously
propagated
um
about two to two and a half months
before um
they're transplanted flowering begins in
september through october and then we're
harvesting our plants uh november
through may
with the harvest ending wind when
temperatures get too warm in the
greenhouse
and one of the bottlenecks that i'm
hearing about from from greenhouse
strawberry growers is it's hard to
source
good tray plants from
propagators so many growers will do
their own propagation in the summer time
where they'll take runner tips and root
them and then grow them on in 125 to 250
milliliter pots
just a few photos
from
greenhouse strawberry production these
are these are plants that are getting
established in this case the the plastic
is used to help prevent
weeds that could that could proliferate
in the soil substrate
as well it could help with some insects
so like thrips for example or fungus
nets so so thrips are on the leaves but
then
they actually pupate in the soil and so
they drop down
and pupate in the soil so that can help
restrict them
here's a view of this greenhouse did not
have supplemental lighting
but they did have photoperiodic lighting
so to to trick the plant into thinking
that it's getting long days which helps
with with initiating more flowers and
more fruit they actually had these
these led lights that have some some far
red light
and those would be operated
four hours per day
during the middle of the night
and here's plants that are coming into
to fruiting and being actively harvested
at this point
um and in japan their market's quite
interesting these berries were selling
for about a dollar per berry and every
berry was high quality
and kind of packed
individually
a little bit about yields
for
for field production
in california we get about 60 000 pounds
per acre per year of course they have
this would be day neutral strawberry
production over several months
per year so that gives us about 1.4
pounds of fruit
per year
our new york field production
is seasonal and then much lower yields
so 5 000 to twenty thousand pounds per
acre per year
um so there are reports that high tunnel
tabletop yields can be double outdoors i
would say that would be like double new
york
uh style yields um and in the greenhouse
uh
we can get
uh
maybe two to two point six pounds uh
fruit per square foot per year
um a high-tech greenhouse in the
netherlands that would be operating
year-round could get up to 4.5 pounds of
fruit per square foot per year
so they had quite high yields maybe
about three times
the california
yields and nine nine times more than new
york field yields
um just a
bit about a couple of common disorders
so i mentioned that we need to maintain
high humidity for a few hours at night
um this is to avoid
strawberry tip burn strawberry tip burn
is a calcium deficiency
that's kind of akin to lettuce tip burn
and this is where the developing
tissues the leaves and the and the brax
a few weeks before the symptoms show up
like this picture on the right um there
was there was poor calcium supply to the
developing tissues
and calcium supply in strawberries um
relies a lot on having positive root
pressure at night so
if you've ever seen gutation on
strawberries maybe in your like outdoor
strawberries
um in the morning where there's there's
actually
water leaking through the the vessels on
the out of the out or edges of the leaf
uh that's showing us that there was
positive root pressure at night
so instead of water being pulled through
through transpiration
um a positive root pressure built up and
and water was pushed through the plant
to deliver calcium
and so so for strawberries that's that's
a good sign we need that that to help
deliver calcium to the plant to avoid
um tip burn which can um
impair our leaf productivity it can also
make fruit unsightly if the if the
um sepals have
this to burn as well
so
common pests and diseases are aphids
spider mites and thrips here are thrips
feeding in the flowers which they love
feeding on pollen
common diseases would be
powdery mildew and botrytis
and so here's here's botrytis for
example
gray mold that's on that's on fruit one
of the control mechanisms that we have
there is to remove any decaying tissue
or dying tissue including any like
over-mature fruit that was not
previously harvested
um at
cornell one of our earlier greenhouse
research projects was to screen
a few different cultivars of
strawberries
and these were all day neutral
strawberries so albion cabrio seascape
and portola
were used in this study
and
we looked at
the bricks or the sugar content of berry
we also looked at at yields
and so this was over
a six-month period in the winter time
and albion
gave us our lowest yields we could
actually get almost twice the yields
with cultivars cabrillo and 50 higher
yields with portola
but one of the things that we found
and is well known with albion is it's a
very sweet berry
and so it's still one of the lb and it
would be probably the most common
greenhouse strawberry varieties that are
used
because of its sweetness
so we have to think about that market
differentiation again could we double
our yield but have a less sweet berry
and would the consumer be okay with that
so i'll
conclude with just a couple trends that
we're seeing for ca strawberries um so
two-thirds of the strawberry production
area in the uk is in soilless substrates
so it's largely moved away from from
field soils
because of the control that you get
um in the netherlands there's 815 acres
of strawberry production under glass
so so a large share of their crop
in
north america and the u.s we're just
starting to see increased interest in
greenhouse strawberry production so new
york we have green empire farms which is
32 acres of greenhouse strawberry
production
in california we have 90 acres of table
top production this would be outdoors
but in soilless substrates
and in canada
we have a couple large farms now with
with greenhouse strawberries and then
we're seeing vertical farms too
so
i thought this was interesting um oishii
is a vertical farm company based out of
new jersey and they shall they sell
strawberries
to high-end markets um this this box
with 11 strawberries actually sells for
fifty dollars
so imagine paying five dollars per
strawberry um
so people are really captivated by this
fruit and they'll still sell them to
kind of top restaurants and high-end
consumers that maybe want to impress
their loved one with with very tasty
strawberries so maybe that's something
we could aspire to
as well and i think we could do it for
much much cheaper in a greenhouse or
high tunnel
with that i will stop and i think i've
used up any time i had for questions but
i'm happy to
sit and monitor the chat and i'll be
responding during the session this
morning um so moving right along our
next presenter is kathy jem dem check
many of you know kathy she is a been a
long time supporter of berry um
production
research and extension efforts in the
northeast she's a senior extension
associate at the penn state university
where her responsibilities are to
conduct applied research into
technologies that improve the
sustainability of berry production with
the overall goal of reducing negative
environmental impacts of production
while maximizing crop productivity so
kathy if you want to share your screen
and
take it away
okay so um so we've been doing some work
um in containerized production of
strawberries um and
and um raspberries for for a few a few
years now
um we had been dabbling with it earlier
so i'm going to give a little history
and talk a little bit about where we've
ended up
um and what conclusions we have so far
and then um primarily concentrate on
some of the pests
so even though you know as neil
mentioned a lot of the work seems to be
you know increasing recently
um you know these are some systems um
different solar systems the growers have
been trying off and on for for over 20
years now in the northeast and sometimes
it's gone okay sometimes there have been
um you know they've given up and moved
on to other things
um now there's something called the ibex
growing system that some folks are
trying some
again it's a lot like some of the other
other systems um
and then of course there are gutters um
that people have tried over time we've
had some growers try like seascape and
mara debois
um so but over this time as this has
been happening it was a you know small
percentage of the production um but a
lot of the questions i was getting and
and so you know just my point in all of
this is that you know i'm glad we're i'm
working out some of these things maybe
because there does seem to be a
long-term need for info looking both
backwards and forwards
um i do want to credit you know some of
the work that it happened to before
before i you know i started working on
anything for sure um these be some
information in the n-ray strawberry
guide back in 1998 about greenhouse
production um cornell had done some work
on greenhouse raspberry production
and so some of this earlier work that
was done really laid the
groundwork for us to move forward um
over on the left you see a photo of a
young famitaker fumi had retired at the
end of
towards the end of last year
and then over on the right are some
gutters we had had back in
2003 and 2000 for um in our penn state
high tunnel complex which the lamont and
mike gorslick have been very
instrumental in getting going so i want
to thank all those folks for
for their help over the years
so more recently um
there has been you know the greenhouse
interest the controlled environment um
interest um with with dr davoda um mail
out at ohio state formerly arizona um
the informational presented and then as
he mentioned um the commercial
operations are
increasing or beginning to increase and
and number and size
neil had mentioned some of the
unprotected culture um
advantages
and so i don't really
um need to go over those so much but i
do want to point out you know one that
growers had mentioned um that is part of
the better quality
is just the more attractive appearance
of the fruit and as we know you know
consumers as folks will say bye with
their eyes and so having those nice
looking berries is important for
marketability
um that is something that um you know
growers have mentioned to me
and then regarding labor there is the
improved organ ergonomics if you have
the system up off of the ground but the
other thing is that um if you have folks
working for you you there is the
predictability
of when they can work and so even if
you're working in high tunnels it
doesn't matter if it's a rainy day um
you can still plan on harvesting on a
schedule or whatever you want to do
in that in that tunnel
so the way we got into this in a bigger
way
was um there was a multi-state scri
project
looking at plastic covers on high
tunnels
for high tunnels and that was led by
eric hanson out at michigan state
cornell was a part of it folks in new
hampshire and vermont
and
also some other states we had some
collaborators in the uk who were a big
help
so we had a part where we were looking
at the different um plastic covers on
the tunnels and the problem was we had a
lot of variation in soil between the
tunnels so bearing in ph and nutrient
concentration or content and so we
wanted to
get away from that and so um and we were
also growing both raspberries and
strawberries
as part of the research we were doing
and so we needed to
decided we needed to move to containers
but we also needed to
be on the
same irrigation setup for both crops and
so we had to find a system that
we could use um also that students who
were working with us could help with
um unfairly you know with only a little
bit of training um or that you know we
felt would function well over over a
weekend without running into
problems and so we were going for about
the most low tech system we could
possibly go for while still growing um
in a soilless media
in containers
and so um
okay and now for some reason my screen
does not want to advance so why is this
hmm
well that is a an interesting little
predicament to have um
did you try the regular advance there's
a there's the little ones down in the
left-hand corner and then sometimes if
you do your own
um on your
your um
you know your little forward arrows yes
yes
is doing it well those are not showing
up at the bottom unfortunately so i
might have to escape out of this and get
back to it
i have never had this happen
well
all right well let me just um see if i
can i'm going to just start sharing yeah
i'm still sharing but i'm going to just
try advancing here i don't know maybe
i'm just stuck on that one and see if we
can go forward from here and if not well
we'll try something else so anyway so we
had to figure the system out pretty
quickly um
and so um you know that unexpression
necessity is the mother of invention so
so we um basically um you know we talked
to a lot of folks so we talked to eric
out at out of michigan state
um and you know took a look at work
other folks had done before us um and
then we did a quick winter trial to try
out some different things where we
basically just
tried a whole bunch of stuff over a
winter um and we did find something that
would work for fairly well for us and
what this was
um
which we're not really you know
wholesale recommending right now but at
work bone our situation was a two to one
per light mix that we had to mix
ourselves it did not have lime added to
it because we have high bicarbonate
waters
and we didn't want to get into having to
acidify
um the water source
with the setup we had and fortunately um
this seemed to work fairly well so you
can see our raspberries um this is the
variety polka in the front um and
josephine in the back these were
actually two separate trials that were
happening i'm at this particular time
and then down in in the right
you see
one of our tunnels where we had albion
uh sweden cabrillo
um and san andreas growing you can see
right there so
so anyhow um so so we worked out
something enough for that trial to be
able to manage um and now we're i'm
continuing to look at some some things
um and again
um we're just trying to find a way of
growing the plants that you know almost
anybody could adopt who has a high
tunnel
um and doesn't have a real strong
background um in greenhouse production
so um so anyway so we tried some things
out last year where we knew we were
doing things the wrong way and long
story short and we figured out all sorts
of ways to make ways to make iron
deficient
and so um my approach is sometimes that
i need to make mistakes before i can
figure out how to fix them and so that's
that's where we were on that one
so anyhow so we're still working it all
out um there's a lot of potential i
think with strawberries um
you know there are interactions between
the media type you're using
um the water source and the fertilizer
you're using so we're trying to
you know work some of that out um our
conclusion we're coming to is it
probably isn't like a one-size-fits-all
approach that'll work for everybody but
there may be some um some ways of doing
this that you know say if you're in a
situation with a high bicarbonate water
then you do this or if you're not then
you do something different
but um we're still working that out
but um some of the overall keys i think
we've come up with is and which i think
everybody else would agree with is that
you do need a
lower ph media um so you know talking
down in the range of mid mid fives to
maybe six seems to help out
um if you have a high bicarbonate water
acidifying the water source or you start
out with good water quality that's good
um micronutrients can be an issue and
then we kind of found that raspberries
were a relative breeze compared to
strawberries so we're going to keep
working on all that um i do want to
just throw up this quote this is what
um laura had said that today's talk
would be about and so i'm going to spend
the rest of the talk
talking about some of the pests we've
seen in our trials
and what we've done to
to manage those um
neil had already mentioned most of these
so this is a great introduction
so um so the past issues we do see um
are quite a bit different than what we
see in the field
um there's you know obviously no rain or
overhead irrigation when you're in a
tunnel or a greenhouse um so that means
we don't have some of the rain splash
diseases like anthracnose we have
actually seen very little grey mold that
may be because in in our trials we've
kept things you know very cleanly picked
um and so we haven't really seen those
issues so much some on raspberries but
but not on the strawberries
so much
and then we see more of the problems and
these are ones that rainfall helps to
control um and so the ones that rainfall
does help to control become worse in a
tunnel
um or you know in a greenhouse as well
so powdery mildew a lot of the smaller
insect pests which we think of as
greenhouse pests so the aphids um
you know mites thrips
um all those sorts of things
so i do just want to mention too that
when you do get into pest issues um
you know the the materials that you
might use
um you need to be um aware of
the fact that the pesticides will need
to be labeled for um
for either greenhouse
production or it may say protected
culture systems or protected culture
production or
sometimes high tunnels are mentioned on
the label as well
um the way it works in pennsylvania and
i'm not sure about other states but it's
defined that if the structure is big
enough that you actually get in it to
work
then it counts as some sort of protected
culture and so the labeling has to be
has to have wording on it that it allows
it to be used
in that situation
so we're going to talk about some of the
diseases we see first so powdery mildew
was was one you know we'd already
mentioned um and so that one when you
know when you don't have rain
um you know you'll tend to see more more
issues with it or at least more symptoms
on the fruit
because the spores
can be washed off by by the rain
and
also just the environment with warm
temperatures and higher humidity are
conditions of powdery mildew really like
so
tends to become a bigger problem
and then um we do find too that our day
neutral varieties are susceptible
to
um
to powdery mildew and um as they're
coming out of you know mostly coming out
of california now the one
that we are using
where the conditions tend to be drier
and they don't have you know as much
resistance as some of our eastern
cultivars
and seascape is one that is really
susceptible
um we haven't seen this on on brambles
in pennsylvania so far
and these are some photos of seascape
from a grower tunnel where the plants
were grown in a gutter system
and they were
very um packed in there pretty tightly
and so we did see
some issues with that um
we've also seen it um on
well seascape but also in a greenhouse
setup that
is just a small scale one
um in
in pennsylvania
and so the um things that are important
for management or to increase
ventilation and air flow as much as
possible we may be fortunate in that on
both of our research sites we have very
windy conditions um and so we haven't
seen that much in a way of problems
lately early on we had seen some issues
and we did use a biofungicide
um called a q10 i believe there were
some um was a trial done in new york
with cucurbits
where it seemed to work for powdery
mildew on that as well i think that was
a detached leaf study though this was on
actual plants we only used it one time
so we don't really have a lot you know
to compare it anything to compare it to
really so that was just an observation
um our one of our plant pathologists
will say you know if you have problems
you can you can help wash the spores off
from the leaves if you use water um i do
want to warn folks that i do know of one
grower who had used
a potassium bicarbonate product um he
was actually trying to control mites but
potassium bicarbonate is for powdery
mildew
um it works on powdery mildew but when
he applied it under high temperature
conditions um the raspberries fell off
of his leaves in a high tunnel so i
don't know if that's something that
would happen very very frequently but
you'd be aware of that another disease
we see is lately frost this is not a
systemic rust so it's not like you need
to pull the plants out to
to um take care of the problem um some
spruce trees are an alternate host on
this one but once it gets on the
raspberries it can persist
um historically it's mainly been a
problem for red raspberries but we know
black raspberries can be affected too
and so we've seen an anjul on a nywat
and a tunnel
um mainly we've seen it on the leaves
and it has it has affected some of the
fruit but it hasn't been a big enough
problem yet to to worry about treating
it when we were in a tunnel tunnel
situation we saw it more so out in the
field though on the fruit
and then i want to mention this is one
that hopefully you can see what we're
looking at here um the contrast and this
photo's kind of tough but um plato's
thorium um we see this on raspberries
there are two different species that
cause it
and so it has some a velvety green
growth will show up on it and so
i'm hopefully you can see my my cursor
here but um what we're looking at is
sometimes it'll be on the receptacles
and some that are just hanging out there
so it's sort of a velvety green color
right here and you can also see one
fruit that we had missed that was
affected by it back here so you might
think that would be grey mold but that
was actually cladosporium
and then sometimes folks will see that
there are just little splotches around
the rim of the raspberry which you're
not seeing on this one here but what it
is
caused by is that sometimes the anthers
get infected by it and then if you have
moist conditions and they lay on the
fruit you get these little splotches of
plato's foreign
around the rim of the berry and these
are really just on the surface but they
still affect the
um marketability in fact the disease
itself tends to be just on the surface
and it can be um rubbed off actually so
anyway so that's one that we do see um
oh in in tunnels occasionally it is a
common um fungus in the environment it's
just one of those things that's sort of
around and it didn't normally
cause problems in the past but part of
the reason we think we might be seeing
it now um is that it is associated with
spotted wing drosophila and it can be in
its digestive tract and it may be
um that when spotted wing drosophila is
moving around or feeding on fruit or
ovipositing it might be introducing it
through the surface um you know there
could be multiple avenues where that is
affecting the fact that we're saying it
more so um so it's worst under high
humidity
tends to be worse or worse in the fall
when we have short days to reduce light
and less drying
so we um at this point we just recommend
trying to ventilate more and keeping the
fruit picked and then trying to control
spider-wing drosophila
as much as you can which we will
um which we will
talk about
also
so um so now we're going to move into
the insects so
um with spotted wing drosophila you know
we typically don't think of it as being
a huge problem in the northeast on our
june bearing strawberries because
um generally by the time the populations
build
we just don't see um you know we don't
see very much much of it we're through
the strawberry season
but with day neutrals either in the
field or in tunnels sometimes um
or if with very late season june bearing
cultivars folks will notice that there
are light soft spots um on the fruit now
that can be mistaken for sun scald but
if you're seeing it on the you know on
the
shady side of the row um it's probably
not
um or um they will mention that it seems
to them that the fruit is melting
and then this tends to become worse in
the fall because that's when the
population is built the highest
and so when that happens um you know you
can kind of tell yourself that it must
just have been the rain in the field or
something like that and maybe you don't
want to look too close but um
one thing i've learned over the years is
that looking at what you're going to eat
under a microscope is always a bad idea
but anyway so what we um see here in
this picture on the left and this was
taken under microscope is a strawberry
um you can tell that the color of of the
fruit is a little bit off it's a little
pinker you know than it than a normal
ripe berry would be so this is a soft
area and if you look at it what you see
is actually an egg and then um
you know there
are basically you know breathing tubes
and so on so right here
is where the egg is and you can see that
under the surface of the fruit where it
has been inserted
and then over on the right um is an
larvae in the fruit and so what you see
are
are basically um you know how it how it
gets its air um with this little
appendage up here in the air and you can
kind of see right along here the outline
of the larvae itself and so it goes
right through here
and so um so that's just something that
you know we need to be aware of
we can have issues with
and then typically spotted will be a
bigger problem in brambles and so again
under the microscope this is blackberry
where you can see a number of um eggs
have been laid in these individual
drooplets
and right over here is an egg
that you can see just underneath the
surface and then this is where the fruit
is softened
and
the skin was rubbed off and you see the
larvae right here so not you know not
what we want to see and then generally
um if the um
when the spiderweight goes through
publication you will see a pupa
typically these will drop to the ground
but here is one that is in a raspberry
fruit
anyway so adults will tend to um hide
out this is in a tunnel where they're on
the underside of the berry we were
hoping with part of a trial that maybe
we could find out whether we could use a
plastic that would tend to you know make
the population and the populations not
one want to move into the tunnel so much
which we did very much see with japanese
beetle
um
but with spotted wing what we found was
if we had a ultraviolet light
transmitting plastics so something like
tough flight for we did see lower adult
adult populations but each adult lies
lay so many eggs that it just didn't
make any difference in the larval
numbers by the time it was all said and
done
so so that one didn't work but
so we've got to find a solution and it
can't exclude with netting
we do have some issues where the tunnels
will tend to get pretty warm in
pennsylvania and so the mites will
multiply faster i do recommend
harvesting frequently
using good sanitation work at the
university of maryland
so that using landscape fabric can help
so that you don't miss fruit
and trust in pyganic are a couple of
options
and there is some movement towards some
upcoming parasitoid releases so that may
be a longer term
solution for us
and then i'm going to talk about mites
so numbers can really you know explode
under a tunnel
um two spotted spider mites which you
see on our left are our common one which
tend to lay a lot of eggs sometimes
we've had some issues with broad mites i
just want to point out with them you
need high magnification
um this floral
and fluorescence here is is really
compressed
and that was a symptom of broad mites
and then this is what an egg looks like
down here at the bottom
where it's kind of a speckled looking
egg but you need a microscope to see
that
we haven't seen issues with cyclamen
mites yet um or
carmen mites which would um actually
just a color variation of two-spotted
spider mite but they could they brought
in on nursery stocks so we could see
those as well
so we um would release predators and
they always seem to work first um
two-spotted spider-mite unless we um
refrigerated them
which i'm talking to carol glenister she
said no you're supposed to keep them
cool not cold and so once we stopped
doing that
that solved that problem and then
sometimes we would try to hold them
overnight or you know for an extra day
if we didn't release them right away um
and that was a no-no also so this is
what a predatory might looks like you
can see right here
moving moving around i'm looking for
mites
so if you want to release predators
you'll need to
talk to your supplier and be prepared
for information on the size of the area
you want to treat
how big your problem is
what your temperature and humidity
ranges are
and they can make a recommendation for
what you can what you can use and they
may recommend reducing the populations
first with you know spraying plants with
water or using insecticidal scope soap
there is a good website also at cornell
on bio controls and predators that has a
lot of great information on it
so if we released early we would use a
combination of amniosulous felasis in
california yes that gives longer term
control so would we release that when we
just see a few leaves that were looking
like this with a little bit of stippling
that worked well for longer term control
and then if we had a really big outbreak
when we weren't paying attention and we
were able to get this one under control
this not every plant looked like this
but we um used phytosolus for simulus
um but that gets really expensive when
you try to release enough mites to clean
something like that up
so grips um here's a thrift feeding on
earth rips feeding on a strawberry and
you can see why it causes the bronzing
because there is surface damage that
it's causing there
and um so that that bronzing is a
problem on strawberries
um sometimes they can cause the seeds to
lift off if the
fruit surface doesn't it can't expand
enough because of damage um powdery
mildew can cause the same thing and
you'll notice this if you notice the
seeds falling off look you can look for
one of the two of those
and then just the fact that they're
around on raspberries and is an issue
and then aphids um
is another concern this is just an a um
aphid population actually on a south
whistle but you can also see a wasp here
that it was peritonizing some of the um
aphids and there's a parasitized one
right there
and so what worked well we we didn't
really have issues at rock springs but
there we always had a population of lace
wings and hover flies
um the larvae on them are predacious no
so we've never used pesticides like 20
years in our high tunnel environment and
so we think we've just built up a good
population of these beneficials we did
have issues um atlantisville which is
their southeast research station and so
what we did there was we knocked them
back with insecticidal soap
with
several sprays of that and then we moved
some potted sweet alyssum into the
tunnel um to attract beneficials and
that seemed to help
so typically our growers will keep these
products on hand to try to knock things
back if they need to quickly and trust
gigantic and insecticidal soap
and that's you know i will mention there
but i do just want to say two to you
know we need to keep our pollinators in
mind when we're applying anything and i
do just want to mention this is a black
raspberry this hole in the end of a cane
is actually a solitary bee egg chamber
there are eggs in this in this cane they
like a hollow soft um center to
um you know to to cane or piece of wood
or cardboard tube and that's not a hole
made by a
board so i just wanted folks to be
aware so it looks like we're right at 10
o'clock laura do we just want to do
questions in the chat or how do you want
to handle this
um why don't we take a question or two
if we have them i think there was um
something about
uh spider-wing drosophila fine issue
during august and september and high
tunnel i think we know the answer to
that yes it is yes
[Laughter]
yes so
does anybody else have another question
regarding pest management or just
general um container issues right now
so um so question how can you tell the
difference between the b egg chamber and
the border hole so
um so these will always be in the very
tip of the cane and so what i will tell
folks is to cut that cane about six or
eight inches down
and if it doesn't go any further than
that then it's not aboard most you know
our pest boards will turn tunnel
further down in the cane and some of
them will even get into the crown area
and then if if it you know if it doesn't
go any further than that then you know
it is just a a b egg chamber and you can
just let that hang out somewhere in your
tunnel there that's safe so that they
can hatch out
so why don't i quickly um just introduce
i'm going to share my screen as well but
i'm going to introduce our next speaker
thank you kathy so much
i'm going to introduce our next speaker
which kathy also introduced me to and
that is mark mcdonald
he started the bee tree berry farm in
belafonte pennsylvania in 2012 with a
small plot of strawberries which has now
grown to 20 acres of sustainably
cultivated
berries and vegetables well good morning
and thanks for having me um
little background about about laura and
myself we've only been farming now for
10 years
we got started a little
a little later in life that
than a lot of folks have
i spent 32 years growing golf turf
and laura spent some time
working in a greenhouse
at a farm market in york county so we do
have a little bit of growing background
and like you said we do have 20 acres
that we planted with mixed berries and
uh
some vegetable crops a few fruit trees
and
couple of chickens
our sales
they all happen
at two farmers markets
we have a small
csa and we also do you pick
strawberries blueberries and
elderberries
um
one thing that we noticed early on when
we were first starting uh our first
couple of years growing strawberries
was the uh
just how everyone everyone wanted them
and this couldn't get enough um
so we were looking for ways to extend
that season
and
we went into uh our first day neutral
third of an acre planting on plastic
in 2014 i believe
and and we tried to grow
on plastic uh for about four years and
um
with organic inputs uh it made it very
difficult to control the anthracnose
primarily
um
i found it very hard to to have a a
a good harvestable crop to take the
market on a weekly basis
so
with that uh we actually went to see
kathy one
i think it was october
probably of 2017
maybe
and uh
we went to look at her low tunnel
production and while we were there
she showed us what was going on in the
high tunnels and that really intrigued
us
um
so we
started the next spring uh with some uh
um
high tunnel production
and uh
you can see here that our first year we
were growing
in bags
uh on the ground
and uh we also had some raspberries
in the background there as well um
we were growing albion
in in one gallon bags and this is just a
two by four frame with some
with some fencing on it to support the
bags
and those bags are
12 to 14 inches on center so
we also had 30 raspberries in the back
there they were grown in
three gallon pots
again with with holes drainage holes in
them and and
everything was fed with a 2720 from
nutriculture
and
again this was due to our high
alkalinity water that we had to deal
with
so
uh our growing mix was uh
the two to one pete the perlite
and uh
you can see here this is our our initial
this is probably our first week of
of uh
planting uh typically we'll get our our
plants the first week of april
and try to get them in the ground within
10 days of receiving
so we'll stick them in
on our on our
benches which you can see now are are
now raised
and you can see we're growing
strictly strawberries in this tunnel
nail the raspberries are
out we actually divided them up and and
put them out in the field a couple years
ago
so we used the pots that the raspberries
were in and raised the benches
which was a a nice aspect um
makes picking a little easier you're
still bent over a little bit but you're
not crawling on the ground which is kind
of nice
um
let's see
so yeah you can also you can see now
we're growing in pots and in one gallon
trade pots as opposed to the one gallon
bags
uh our first two years we grew
in in the white bags with the black
white on black bag
and uh
didn't like the kind of the fact that we
had to throw everything away
so we we've gone to the black pots
um
for two years now
and uh
it seems to be working out okay uh we're
actually gonna split it again this year
i'm gonna go 50 50 with the with the
white bags to the black pots and try and
get dialed in as to what really works
best for us
because we're still again this will be
our fifth season and we still have a lot
to learn
i guess the biggest problem that we've
had
other than than crawling along the
ground to pick and again we've
eliminated that with raising the pots
we did we have had some powdery mildew
issues
and a little bit of thrip problem
nothing major nothing really really
crazy but
enough to have an impact on our harvest
and fertility our uh our irrigation
water is is uh
really not up to
the standards that we'd like um
so we do have to really pay attention to
how we're feeding
um our harvests
are
our uh
i guess our first year data we didn't
really have any any real uh information
on our first year harvest um
in 2018 uh
2019
uh we had a uh
1046 marketable pints and i i need to
mention that we do have we have 700 pods
so uh
we were getting
that was about 732 pounds uh
our first year that was an average of
of 0.7 pounds per
per pint which is how we
we measure our yield because we do sell
by the pint
so i see a question about plant runners
um
we
basically when they get in my way uh
going down the aisles if they're if
they're if i'm tripping over them which
will happen
later in the season
i remove them
we do go through once and and pick the
first flowers
and we do
one major
cutting of runners uh early on in the
season
but after that we pretty much let them
go and again unless they're they're in
our way then we uh take care of them
but um
for our second
our second year on these raised benches
and uh in the black pots we changed our
mix
uh away from the the uh pete perlite mix
that had been recommended
and we went with uh
a bag mix bk25
and
all the same fertility programs same
planting programs etc and our yield
increased
from a pound per plant to 1.3 pounds per
plant
so
you know again we're getting uh
i got
1273 marketable pints
out of this little this little thousand
square feet 1100 square feet of of the
growing space
which you know it's not a lot of of
poundage
but when you're when you're looking at
uh
the return on investment
um
you know we were able to get six dollars
a pint uh at market
um
for our for our day neutrals
and uh that's that's a pretty good i
think that's a pretty good return uh
four thousand square a little over a
thousand square feet of growing space
um
last year we had a little issue again we
went back to pete perlight
um
and
we we harvested
155 pounds
last year um
we actually turned the water off in
early september because it just there
was no flower production
late mid-season on we had some
this is this is last year we had a
little bit of fruit early and some
flower production early
and
as the season went on
our flower production basically stopped
so we just couldn't see the the need to
continue with it last year so
we have ordered plants again for this
year uh albion again
our thoughts are to go on um
back with the bk25
and uh
again i want to split it up with with
the bags versus the pots
keep up with the same fertility program
and see where it takes us
something else we're thinking about
doing this year
is
putting up a small caterpillar
tunnel
and growing day neutrals directly in
soil under plastic
we're still debating what to do with
that
so
i guess our
i guess i can answer any questions uh if
you have if you have any
uh please
thanks mark that was great and there are
some questions in the chat box and um i
don't know if you guys are if i'm
sharing everything or what i'm sharing
actually but um there was a question
from chuck mead about flavor and
firmness comparing greenhouse
and tunnel versus the field fruit did
you have any comments on that
yeah like like neil was saying earlier
um
the the early berries in the tunnel
um
really are are are not up to
the field flavor uh
so if you can continue to grow
throughout the in the field a little
later maybe with melvina or something
like that
it'll get you into at least
a time where the tunnel berries start to
pick up in flavor really mid-august you
really notice a big change
in the flavor and once once mid-august
september get there
they're probably the best berries
flavor-wise that we have all season
great thank you and then you talked
about the plant runners and then mike
knuckles this is actually uh close to
what you were just saying the harvest
season
start and stopping when what is your
like average starting and average
stopping in the in the tunnel
well again we'll start
when berries are present we'll harvest
them
uh so we'll start harvesting in june
late
third week fourth week of june and we've
gone as far as
thanksgiving it all it all depends on
the year basically and now obviously the
yields uh early and later are are small
um
our biggest
i'm trying to see uh
august and september
typically are our our best
months for harvest for the biggest yield
but um
we do have berries available i've taken
them to farmers market
until the middle of the middle of
november
great
um jim has a question about changes with
the media just wondering if you've
finally if you've settled on something
that you really like or
you're just kind of still experimenting
yeah we're still trying to figure that
out uh we actually did a little work
with kathy last year
she was doing a media study
uh
atlantisville
and we did a few
uh pots here as well with the same
products and unfortunately our yields
last year just didn't work out uh
because of our flowering issue but um
there was a core product uh
that
our plants look good growing in it um
i'm going to talk i want to get some
information hopefully
on how their yields were down
at the research farm
um and go from there but right now i
think we're going to stick with bk25
unless we we see some
good information coming out of their
study
all right great
um if
before we answer the last two questions
i i wondering if andy or natasha could
put the
link to the dec credit survey which
folks have to do that
at the end of the session
and in order to get the dc credits but
we can keep talking about some of these
questions
and we have a question about any problem
with kinking of the fruit trusses
thinking of the fruit trusses not uh
not something we've experienced
now
okay that that has been a problem
um for some people that they will sit on
that edge of the pot
and they can you know just because of
weight of the fruit or
the sharpness of the edge to provide a
little kink and it kind of shuts off
everything to that fruit um as it grows
so that is something to be aware of
i was going to say we've we've seen that
in some of our greenhouse strawberries
and so we've ended up moving to this
trough that has a smooth kind of curved
edge
and that helps and then otherwise i've
seen some growers um run tape not sticky
tape but like
uh raised up a little bit so they can
they can position the trusses kind of
resting on that soft tape
and laura can can i jump in with a few
things too so um so first on the fruit
trusses yeah so helping keep the media a
little higher will can help with that
too if that settles into the pots
then the trusses are up and then they're
bending over so so that's one thing that
can help um and that's part of the
reason that we are still with bags it's
just they just sort of
you know fold down
um as far as the low yields i
i was having some conversations with
mark pritz and also kim lures atlantis
film or plantersville beltsville for
some reason they were saying really high
they knew
yeah they were seeing less flowering
last year
we didn't really have that problem at
landisville so we have no idea what's
going on it seemed very hit or miss and
so i don't i don't know what what was
going on there you know um
with mark's because we i think we had
the same plant source and so that was
really baffling
um and then when i and out of our trial
atlantisville so what worked really well
as far as the media goes um
is
um
[Music]
it's called bc5 plus plus it's actually
the media they're using in ontario and
the netherlands and it's a very
different mix that one worked really
well for us better than anything else we
had tried and the two to one people like
um was really at the bottom
for in that trial other ones did better
we tried five other five other ones but
that bc5 then was the sixth one and that
one did the best
um and then the other thing is that with
some and we're working with folks at the
hershey school they've actually moved to
using a petunia feed which provides a
lot more iron that helps
there's also another new fertilizer out
of ico
i think it is that has a lot more iron
and micronutrients and in forms that are
available at higher ph's if you get into
issues so next you're going to be
looking at some of our best media with
our best fertilizers and
try to get a better handle on that so we
can hopefully you know answer these
questions
that's great and i know about william
has a question that doesn't look like a
very quick question but possibly um
you're for what is your fertility
program
and i want to say while uh mark is
formulating an answer for that i would
like to encourage people we don't have a
formal evaluation which is is my
oversight
however i would we we're going to try to
put something together but if you have a
thought while you're sitting here
thinking about these
um questions please put topics that you
would like if for instance if you want
to see more in-depth information on
container culture now's the time to tell
us so that we can try to
follow up on that but
uh mark i don't know if you can
do that uh question justice in a minute
or two about the fertility program
ours is really simple uh basically we'll
start the year with with the plant
marvel 27 20
for high alkalinity soil or water
and and stick with it um if we have an
issue i'll add a little
take uh something with a little
manganese and iron in it uh to take care
of some some chlorotic looking issues
but other than that
um
that's that's pretty much it for us
pretty simple
well thank you i i don't want to cut
this short but we're about seven minutes
over our time to adjourn i really want
to thank our speakers um it's a this is
something that growers are always asking
me about and i'm really happy we have
expertise and a
grower that's willing to share um you
know what's going on there so thank you
so much everyone
we will
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu